quella tutti ragazzi prendono di questo
video sono fa vj che oggi siamo tornati
su è più dopo anni credo c'era hitler
l'ultima volta che ho giocato è più il
primo episodio ogni tanto lo posso anche
che cazzo cliccato non ho neanche letto
ormai ormai vado così a caso regala
ormai sono abituato welcome to my torno
benvenuto nella mia tortura ma chi cazzo
sei o da quello di star wars la roba non
ho neanche capito don't touch è che
avessi proprio voglia di toccare non lo
sciacca ridotto così comunque possa
capire un attimo qual è il punto di
questo livello cioè a una tortura
io devo torture alla gente bello ciao
come stai
ma quanta bella barba che c'è è presente
un nuovo rasoio gillette gillet il
meglio di un nonno che lavoro della
madonna che ha fatto store rasoio
guardali che non c'è un filo di barba
che sarà tortura che mi faceva mia madre
quando prendevo 4 a scuola va bene è la
cuesta lì attaccata proprio sul pene
meraviglioso cappello mi piace questo
gioco grazie a dio ragazze
sorridi sì ma con quella faccia che ti
trovi col cazzo sorrido ecco qua
perfetta picture la foto in che sarà un
museo tipo
ma che bella a doha da che gran foto
lega questa la metterò sul comodino un
giorno è più il super mario bros
beh proprio questo è che ancora non ho
provato un super mario sua piece decente
che sia proprio coi contro maroni ma sei
serio ma verame che figo steve se il
nuovo superman ragazzi super steve gross
fenomeni sfracello la testa non so
perché è giusto presentimento e invece
no cazzo cazzo cazzo no io dove ma come
mano che mi scoprono i toponi sopra si
stupra buddha air one ha stuprato avere
pazienza e l'ostacolo di è più il più
stupido che possa esistere sono uscito a
morire e genia i non so come arte come
mischio fatta morire mamma l'ho preso
preso
dopo super steve gross voglio anche
super steve galaxy ragazzi è stata una
figata pazzesca vasche turno facciamo
prima questo che voglio vederlo di
potenza perfetto primo basta trovo world
facciamo questo mi sembra più carino
disegna il tuo mondo perfetto ha bevuto
del gene questa matita che lo sta
facendo matita torna a casa 6 ubriaca
sapete che ci sono delle volte in cui
vorreste capire come ci finite in certe
situazioni no io non ve lo dico come si
son finito così non ve lo voglio dire
suscita beccare l'ostacolo più brutto
della storia ok perfetto look è morto ma
va bene madonna cosa ho fatto già sto
facendo e che non so come nonno ciak mai
verrai finto davvero non ha beneficato
israele ma sarei contento world trovo
decente facevano sword trovo come sapete
che cosa rompe i [ __ ] di una spada
neymar onyx una spada con luke nei
maroni esattamente
ok bellissime robe su soppresso nota che
è toccato vabbè robur soccer 16.0
finalmente un gioco di calcio decente
che fa concorrenza fifa vero zio con le
neymar
si vede che neymar fatto proprio come
neymar se la posso ancora fare perché
per giocare a calcio non ha bisogno di
gambe
non ho bisogno
certo che se il portiere piuca goso
della storia che gol
la mano de dios la mano dell iss è
bravissimo a guardarlo
guardalo mamme non è neanche fallo mi sa
ancora che fair play fatevi provare
un'altra volta voglio vedere se riesco a
mamma che attraversa con la testa porca
vacca epic slam dunk preferito mancavano
le pisa
che io sappia vale come il canestro vero
guardalo che professional guardalo mamma
qualcuno mi sa spiegare che cosa ho
appena fatto perché non lo so che i per
fight como ma vero killed creeper before
it plaza puccini il clipper prima che
esploda va bene se con craftare un fa vj
vediamo che ok però una corona mi chiedo
non lasciate 4 che cazzo vuole di più 3
esplodi cazzo
seppur verso ma che full verso il 99 per
cento impossible era questo che
aspettavo da quando iniziata alla madame
ma siccome e nero posso mettere di
sfondo dei pony grazie perfetto adesso è
molto più molto ma molto più figo io ho
i miei pony ce la faremo lo sto già vero
ragazzi bravi bravi bravi e sono loro
che mi danno la forza dai source niente
non ho mai fatto un impulsivo e così
cazzo ok ok ok va bene va bene va bene
va bene certo un paio di zero oggi ho
vinto art un target a lo prendo nel
borgo effetto è un'amica c'è un amico le
mani di merda e va bene l'ho preso l'ho
presa ho preso preso viva di ordinare
delle medaglie non so chiedo a dettargli
neuer confezione da 6 2 alla madonna
la donna barista trombando ragazzi cosa
riguarda che tutti che si limonano è io
sono single don heck scusami anche suoi
di simbolo però tutti i manettari troppo
non muoiono mai fino a st rivali
vandalismo che storia d'amore è sempre
migliore è quella di twilight
eccola la perfetta ma vecchie dolci
anche dopo la morte ci siamo ragazzi
fatevi provare un paio di miei livelli
prima che fa vj fidati ai suns già che
parla inglese mentre il titolare in
italiano non mi devo fidare un cazzo
prove non fate palleggio non importa dai
così ma è così che sono però vai così
che sono pro e ragazzi sto scalando
l'everest cosa
cortex perché c'è cortex che è stato
brutalmente colpito dagli occhi ma
[ __ ] fa vj zero per cento testato
cosa vuol dire questo scenario mi
ricorda vagamente con l'ict mario e se
bloccano reggesse lab e pazienza che non
funzionano tutti o mio dio è invece
eto'o [ __ ] avendo al cesso mi ha
[ __ ] rido cesso ma dai è vero che mi
blocca la strada sto bastardo ma poi c'è
si devono rovinare
ma vai a cagare spingi spingi è brutto
dire questa frase in un cesso prodi
spingi dai che vai giù vai giù va giù
bravo zio bravo bravo bravo viste
piacendo mi sta piacendo mi sta piacendo
bravo ecco mi sei piaciuto fratello mi6
fottutamente piaciuto fa vj volante fa
vj e un cetriolo questo livello e per
far ejei ha passato tutto il giorno a
farlo vediamo che cosa incredibile
uscita grazie all'in certo che ho paura
adesso e va con annuncia che dai
famiglie se un uomo sei un cetriolo
ho dei dubbi per questo livello non è
stato maltrattato alcun cetriolo va bene
è sponsorizzata da pc protezione
cetrioli italiani
alice mi sa che cosa cazzo fumi la
mattina come si chiama fa vj fabio fabio
dj quanti anni a favilla ebbene sì ho
capito ma il senso di questo caso qual è
il suo cognome ostuni lorenzo ostuni
meravigliosa il mio mi fa cagare
ecco perché l'ho coi baffi si chiama
toni perché somiglia sono anno perché se
il suo zio
ma chi è che partì qui alice per
cortesia quando è nato 8 aprile 7 aprile
sbagliato come sbagliato è giusto che fa
eco a [ __ ] nuovo amica lettera è che
il pallone anche se caccia vas è
arrivato fin qua
scegli il tuo premio una casa una
famiglia bella domanda facciamola family
fa la family la femi felice se non c'è
luca e allora va a fan culo però che
bello famiglia e tesoro e che ti qui
grazie perché ciò due mogli
vabè due mogli meglio che one mentre
bomb una all'altra sta a guardare con i
ragazzi conclude l'episodio fa vj e un
cetriolo ce l'ho nel cuore ormai e
quindi ragazzi niente dire che possono
chiudere che l'episodio non mi piace se
anche voi pensate che i cetrioli possano
conquistare il mondo un giorno perché è
una roba che secondo me va beh staremo a
vedere anche a causa di facebook e come
livida papà tiziano
la loro passione del richiamo
[Musica]
e tanto piacere
basta che non me lo metti nel sedere
piaciuta si fuma cosa sai di avere